Ever since I was a kid.
This just this innate sense of alienation that was a part of me all the time and
I don't know where it came from.
[inaudible]
why I was in the magic was it because I think it was a medium to further
understand reality.
I wanted to know the truth of how that car disappeared,
how that coin disappeared.
I was walking through life with this veil of really anxiety,
written thoughts.
What does this person think of me?
What clothes am I going to wear today?
I just had this enlightenment anywhere.
I realize that all of these really mundane worries was completely unnecessary.
There's no physical brick wall till like constrict us from doing what we want,
you know,
and I realized that it really doesn't matter what that person thinks of me at
all.
Psychedelics were almost in giant magic trick to me.
I would see something but under the influence it was actually an illusion of
something else.
It wasn't enough to figure out how to card trick worked anymore.
I wanted to see how the trick worked in life.
I wanted to lift the curtain of reality.
What is the inner mechanism that strings everything together?
When I would skateboard under these substances,
I felt like part of the earth rolling the wheels on the asphalt.
Every time I would shuffle cards,
it just felt right.
I felt like a universe orbiting planets in my head.
I felt almost too connected to my surroundings.
I was reading my ego to the point where I didn't associate with Pierre to the
point where I didn't feel human anymore.
It was just consciousness,
but when you're living in Orange County at age 19 you can't go around saying
your consciousness,
you know?
I didn't understand how people didn't see how I viewed things and everybody that
I tried to talk to,
it came off really forced and really awkward.
I would be alone in my room a lot.
Painting is surrounding myself with art,
but I'd be doing all of this stuff by myself.
Depression really started coming in because I didn't relate to anybody around
me,
not my parents,
not my friends.
I didn't have any friends anymore.
Yeah.
You got to a point where I was longing for human connection at this point.
I knew what it felt to be the outcast.
I knew what it felt like to be an alien for a while,
but now it was time to be back on earth.
When you're that far out in space,
it takes a few light years to come back on earth.
You know?
I had to find out how to be a human being again.
I was intentionally putting myself back into the illusion.
I realized that it's not bad to be part of Volusia necessarily.
The best part about a magic trick is being fooled.
That's where the show is.
He can't be behind the scenes all the time.
There's no show anymore.
I wanted to be back on stage again.
I want it to be performing with everybody
are here for a reason.
[inaudible]
I've been fairly financially comfortable because of my parents,
a good portion of my life,
but no,
financially we have to get rid of this giant studio that I was completely
blessed with.
You have to find a new home and we have to find a way to make ends meet and
oh no.
It really sucks.
Like it's been really somber about it.
Right now I'm just trying to figure out where I belong in human society.
I don't know how to make stuff that makes money.
I tried to make art that reaches out to a bigger audience at times,
but you know,
that's for everyone else to decide really.
And,
and what I've been struggling with recently is just that all of the material
that I've made throughout the years,
does it mean anything to,
it's really unfortunate,
but I guess eventually the baby has to exit the womb,
right?
The baby has to see the world.
I don't think life is only about happiness anyway,
I think.
I think life is a lot deeper than that.
It's a lot more important to grow and to be happy.
No,
I,
I don't know where to go exactly,
but hopefully the universe has a path carved out that I can walk down on.